dream on you know how important post
game fashion come on man
what the hell come on i love jared man
that's my spartan dog but that's
ridiculous
come on come on jerry come on man i like
that michael no
no man i wouldn't expect it must be hot
in memphis
just go all the way rudy man take the
towel all the way bruh
i like the shirt and the t-shirt come on
man
all of them could have worked just not
together well you're not at the beach
the shorts could have worked but now at
the beach come on man you can't wear
that to the game
to the game to the game
damn to the game yeah that's a wrap for
inside the nba dream i've been great
having you with us we look forward to
the next couple of nights with you come
on man
please dress appropriately for tomorrow
shut up i don't care i don't feel like
defending shorts no you can't whistle
you said you like that that's not good i
like that no that's not good
he probably got some purple pants
[Laughter]
it's like he's about to be a guest on
the steam room
oh man i i'll put a shirt on